wie wir schon jetzt diskutiert haben ich
glaube wir leben heute wirklich einen
gesamt residenz losen krieg das ist ein
angriffskrieg seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
und dieser krieg hat drei dimensionen
weil wir sehr oft den unseren der warte
nur über die militärische dimension
sprechen die erste in dem ensi und das
ist die militärische ich glaube herr
putin hat auch damit gar nicht gerechnet
dass dem trainer so einen großen
widerstand leisten wird es gibt auch
informationen das eigentlich am ersten
tag schon eingenommen werden sollte wir
sehen auch sehr viele soldaten die jetzt
russische soldaten dient und kräne
sterben nach offiziellen angaben des
ukrainischen
verteidigungsministeriums sind das circa
6000 soldaten die gestorben sind
ich glaube was wovor ich persönlich ja
so ein bisschen angst habe dass den
krieg dauert schon lange für putins ich
glaube vorstellungen und in zukunft
können wir nur damit rechnen dass die
angriffe auf die zivilbevölkerung noch
ein brutaler werden die zweite dimension
das ist nämlich die
betriebs cyberangriffe die
noch vor dem offenen krieg erfolgten die
cyber angriffe allerdings was ich glaube
schon positiv ist dass die ukrainische
regierung auch jetzt nicht schon stärker
hat dagegen vorzugehen
es wir wissen auch dass internationaler
hacker jetzt sich verein tragen und
angriffe auf das russische
verteidigungsministerium gemacht haben
und die datenbanken wurden gelegt die
kreml seite war lahmgelegt russischer
gelenkten medien wurden auch gehackt und
zum beispiel jungfische höhener wurde
dann über
russische sender dann verbreitet und das
wird stattfinden diese cyberangriff wir
sind heute auch zeugen dieses cyber
krieges ich glaube der dann stattfinden
weiter stattfinden wird und den dritter
dimension das ist nämlich propaganda
aber wir reduzieren sie sehr oft diese
propaganda auf fake ist und das ist
nicht der fall ein provokantes
informationen die wir von seite russland
erleben hat zum ziel einer parallelwelt
zu schaffen und kann die menschen nicht
erreichen man sieht dass
man auch mit der russischen soldaten
spricht zum beispiel wenn sie ihre
mutter anrufen und einige sagen ja ihr
kämpft aber für die heimat oder zb mit
einer russischen bekannten gesprochen
und gesagt
du hast dann kann ich mit meinem vater
nicht sprechen obwohl er intelligent ist
und englisch spricht aber er glaubt
wirklich daran dass das in tschernobyl
die atomwaffen stationiert sind und dass
die ukraine eine atombombe auf moskau
werfen möchte und daher ist es für mich
ich glaube schon die frage wie werden
wir in zukunft mit solchen parallelen
welten umgehen und was können wir
dagegen machen
erfahrt was sagen sie dazu ich finde
diese analyse absolut bestechend weil
das natürlich zeigt wie moderne
kriegführung abläuft die ist hybrid in
sicht besteht aus mehreren komponenten
ineinander übergehen und gerade jetzt im
zeitalter der digitalisierung ist gerade
diese information war fährt total also
sehr sehr stark das darf man nicht
unterschätzen
denn damit wird letztlich unser mindset
gesteuert und das was wir denken und
fühlen welche und das ist natürlich sehr
psychologisch einerseits nicht aber den
psychologischen faktoren in der modernen
kriegsführung auch die bleiben ein sehr
massives ganz ganz wichtiges instrument
der kriegsführung das ist vollkommen
klar und das machen die russen auch
recht und genauso im cyber bereich das
ist jetzt eine neue dimension die durch
die auch die digitalisierung der land
kriegführung dazu gekommen ist die man
nicht mehr ausschließen kann die
parallel läuft und teilweise auch schon
vor dem angriff beginnen ab lief nicht
und dann gibt es diese klassische
militärische dimension wo die russen
natürlich was ihre hauptwaffensysteme
anbelangt eine massive überlegenheit
haben gegenüber der ukrainischen armee
das kann man sich ausrechnen sie haben
ja auch
nachschub ohne ende das heißt sie können
personal und material noch weiter da
reinschieben das ist die militärische
dimension allerdings muss man auch sehen
zur militärischen dimension gehört auch
diese kann moral nicht und die ist bei
den ukrainern enorm stark nicht dieser
starke patriotismus wo ich mir auch sage
als deutschland mein gott ein bisschen
von dem könnte uns auch ganz gut tun
recht da haben wir eigentlich zu wenig
davon und wo man dann aussieht dass ich
diese kampfmoral wirklich so stark sein
kann dass sie selbst diese materielle
überlegenheit so ein stück wald
ausgleichen kann hierdurch ganz gerne
ganz kurz paar ronzheimer rey noch ein
paar wie sehr spürst du diesen
patriotismus und den kampfgeist in kiew
ja dieser patriotismus es wahnsinnig zu
spüren und ist emotional und bei jedem
aufgeladen gerade eben als ich mit den
klitschko brüdern zusammen war da merkt
man dass in jeder pore sozusagen ja die
beiden riesen die dort stehen und sagen
nein sie bleiben hier sie kämpfen weiter
die geschlossenheit im land und darüber
sprechen dass es jede minute los gehen
kann und die noch mal einfach erklären
wie sehr die ukraine an ihrem land
hängen und dieses land nicht aufgeben
werden von da ich stimme ich da total zu
dass das so ist und auch mich
beeindruckt dieser patriotismus aber
frau mendig hat aus meiner sicht ein
sehr wichtigen punkt aufgeworfen ich
weiß nicht ob am ende die
militärische oder auch der patriotismus
diesen krieg entscheidet sondern man
muss es ja realistisch betrachten
irgendwann würde wladimir putin wenn er
das gesamte militär nimmt das er hat und
ihnen die sanktion völlig egal sind wird
er in welcher form auch immer kiew sehr
wahrscheinlich einnehmen können das kann
viel länger dauern als er das plan aber
wenn er mit allen waffen drauf geht ja
hat und aus kiew sagen wir ein neues
aleppo macht dann wird er es irgendwann
schaffen davon gehe ich zumindest aus
deswegen ist die frage um so wichtiger
was passiert mit den informationen mit
der wahrheit die wahrheit was ist
wahrheit was ist lüge und wie sehr
schafft putin ist weiterhin aus wahrheit
heraus lüge wahrheit zu machen und das
schafft er immer noch viel zu viel wir
haben zwar proteste gesehen aber es sind
keine massenproteste wir erleben wenn
unser kollege peter tiede dort in
russland unter fix ist und dort bilder
aus kiew zeigt dann sagen die menschen
nein das ist gelogen die bilder stimmen
nicht das sind nazis über all das
überhaupt diese mehr der nazis der
ukrainische nazis sicht seit 2014 halten
kann ich weiß noch als ich das erste mal
gehört habe auf dem majdan und vitali
klitschko und sagte guck mal die
erzählen wieder ich sei ein nazi und ich
dachte nur so ja keine ahnung was für
ein bullshit ja aber dass sich sozusagen
daraus dieses diese macht entwickelt hat
die diese geschichte oder diese
propaganda trägt und ein krieg kann
putin gewinnen aber er muss vor allem
die propaganda gewinnen damit er diesen
krieg verkaufen kann und da müsste ich
uns schon die frage stellen wie kann das
passieren wir wollen ja keine propaganda
machen wir wollen wahrheitsgetreu
berichten wir wollen fakten zeigen aber
in russland werden diese frage wie eben
nicht gezeigt und da würde mich
tatsächlich auch eine militärische
perspektive zu der frage interessieren
welche art der kriegsführung für das
ergebnis am ende vielleicht sogar
entscheidend ist ich wollte allerdings
noch mal darauf eingehen das geht nicht
darum dass der weiß welches propaganda
wird betreibt auf gar keinen fall was
wir nicht gemacht haben ihm auch
deutschen fernsehen wir haben zum
beispiel putin nicht so richtig sprechen
lassen oder alle diese propagandisten
usw die hass sprache ich glaube das
haben wir in der rede von boden jetzt
erlebte die wurde geduldig und wir haben
das unter der haut gespürt man muss die
menschen sprechen lassen und die anderen
können darüber urteilen und wir haben
zuviel interpretiert und das ist jetzt
der deswegen möchte ich noch mal betonen
gar keine propaganda betreiben aber man
muss sich überlegen wie können wir
natürlich ist das wollte ich ihnen auch
gar nicht das wollte ich ihnen das
wollte ich ihnen gar nicht unterstellen
oder das habe ich auch gar nicht
interpretiert meine frage war er wie
damit umzugehen sein soll dass in
russland die dinge weiterhin so
dargestellt werden wie sie dargestellt
werden und das bedeutet dass immer noch
eine so große vielzahl glaubt wie sie ja
auch da
über ihren vater berichtet haben dass da
im westen schlimmes passiert ja das ist
ich glaube sehr auch gute frage an die
experten zu sagen die sich mehr im it
bereich auskennen aber was mich
überrascht hat ist zum beispiel diese
hacker auch geschafft haben für eine
gewisse zeit ihre bilder über gelenkten
medien zu verbreiten das ist die frage
ich glaube sehr an die leute können sie
wirklich zum beispiel zukunft solche
über solche medien auch ihre
informationen verbreiten und auch ihrer
sozialen medien aber da hab ich ja ganz
ruhig weiß die zeit drängt aber ganz
kurz nochmal wir reden über propaganda
und wir sehen die ganze zeit über
russland und ukraine können wir bitte
auch bei uns hingucken ich möchte daran
erinnern dass vier staatliche russische
medien ihren sitz in berlin haben und
auf deutsche berichten ja das ist einmal
sputnik dass es jetzt erst einmal rtl de
das war für rtl deutsche nennt sich also
auch noch andauern und das ist red fish
und das ist rapid diese große video
agentur die bestimmen den diskurs wir
haben schon oft auch bei uns sogar bei
bild.de die position gehabt dass wir
sagt haben jetzt müssen wir einst von
rugby einkaufen wir müssen den kreml
finanzieren weil die diese mittel
aufbringen dass sie überall sind
beispielsweise bei julian assange vor
der botschaft in london waren die zum
beispiel und viele andere sachen und das
ist unglaublich gefährlich das geht bei
uns vor der haustür ab aktuell nur so
dass es auch einmal gesagt dass klagte
abily gegen
rappi und rt also diese russische
propaganda seiner ging vier artikel die
ich geschrieben habe also auch dieser
realistischen putin ist muss dieser läge
die dass diese propagandisten uns
gerichtlich verbieten wollen die
wahrheit zu sagen und das geht in
unserem rechtsstaat ja dass das ist
wahnsinn insofern alles gut wenn man
nach moskau guckt wenn man nach kirkuk
aber bis nach berlin und deutschland
gucken wo die russische propaganda
extrem aktiv ist